[Music]
accent in birth tourism news submitted
by open your mind federal authorities
have charged 20 people in a crackdown on
birth tourism I thought it was bird
tourism oh my god it's popular the world
probably goes to do bird-watching you
know but as many you know what this
probably is it's like you ever heard
anchor babies yeah of course come to
America pop out your kids here and then
they'll be naturalized citizens exactly
where birth tourism is oh that's right
yeah which is actually a legal thing Wow
you can legally come to America are you
pregnant and give birth here if you're
willing if you're able to cover the
medical expenses and if you are able to
enter legally through like an valid visa
and you don't lie to customs why not cuz
to me what's it called yeah right yeah
yeah why would a bunch of people want to
come here cuz I heard it's a real
[ __ ] here from everyone in the
comments all the time with that
naturalized citizenship that's pretty
pretty good deal there mm-hmm so federal
authorities have charged 20 people in
SoCal in a crackdown on birth tourism
and this it was all led by this one
Chinese woman knew it I knew it sounds
like some Chinese operation no there's a
lot of them yes they they were there
were raids back in 2015 so they kicked
the door down there's just 50 pregnant
ladies inside yeah we're the big hotels
they've like we're in tell them a ton of
rooms and the hotels and stuff are
inside her [ __ ] so no hotels in Orange
in the counties of Orange Los Angeles
and San Bernardino and so what they
would do is they would charge these very
wealthy or like well-off Chinese women
and they would charge him 20,000 to
80,000 Wow and that would include
medical expenses and so they would tell
the claim of these women on how to hide
their pregnancy they would tell him to
stop in Hawaii right down Trump
International Hotel as the place that
you're gonna be staying at
formication funny um good meaning yeah
mm why Trump because no one's staying
there it's like a little bit of a [ __ ]
you well is live in 2015 oh yeah 2016 e
alright no yeah so actually stayed at
that Hotel when I got engaged nikki is
[ __ ] pretty dope in Waikiki I was it
gold I don't know I got a good deal on
it I use Hotwire and that was the one
that came up and I was I got [ __ ] it's a
good deal okay maybe that's a good deal
that could be so then they instructed
these women to write that down as where
they're gonna save like for customs and
then they booked a flight from Hawaii to
LA and that's when they would come here
and give birth here and they would stay
for about three months I believe so like
after like postpartum and everything
until they're ready to leave and this
was back when the one-child policy was
still happening right because it was it
was finally cut in 2016 so this that's
why women were doing this but the fact
that I've been knowing like this type of
operation since like the 90s oh yeah
just cuz I'm Chinese and I did all kinds
of stories from my mom and the Chinese
newspaper and Oh I mean everyone does it
like Mexicans there all the time - yeah
oh that's ridiculous trying to [ __ ]
open up your mind don't say a bunch of
[ __ ] do you that's not the kind of
racist to me yeah yeah so they're saying
that birth tourism is part of a cultural
fabric now in China said back in um did
you know that they only let in like 68
thousand immigrants total a year in the
US and they're trying to make it smaller
you know I love about this country we
blow the [ __ ] out of Libya we blow the
[ __ ] out of all of Africa Yemen we
[ __ ] lay your Yemen with bombs and
then we're like an orifice
[Laughter]
the Masters are trolling OD oh yeah so I
forgot to mention the reason why I'm so
then like they'll end up returning to
China and back with the one-child policy
the government can't punish the parents
for violating the birth control rules
because technically that second child
was a US citizen so American baby no
yeah so I thought that was the loophole
I wish Chinese people committed sexier
crimes because I you got Martin Scorsese
right like drug-dealing all those
Italian mob crime like if we had a
budding Martin's Asian Martin Scorsese
like these type of stories this doesn't
have the same vibes as Goodfellas no
it's just like a bunch of pregnant
ladies do you put a really cool spin on
it that's that'll be the challenge right
it was a spit I'm pregnant dude I don't
know man like I'm imagining like
something like crazy like like kingpin
leader like like old Chinese lady that's
like managing all these like hotels and
stuff like that there's like a [ __ ] ton
of people and then there's a bunch of
people that you have to like you just
may be the exact seeds no I don't like
some crazy you can't pitch it all pitch
okay picture a bunch of pregnant ladies
back exactly what I imagined picture a
line of pregnant ladies walking through
an airport all right this is a trailer
all right now Gimme Shelter by the
Rolling Stones is playing up you're
welcome
let's [ __ ] head open ow yep and
they're looking suspicious and they walk
by an airline pilot and give me shelters
plan yes FBI trust me every time you go
to your trailer and I Dallas it
it was giving shows always like a
Vietnam War thing or like or hi Steve
yeah or just take a [ __ ] look at movie
put that as the backtrack on the trailer
and you're like that looks sick it does
yeah it's always retro I've gotta be
ready next movie a people with glasses
like you're wearing right now to like
yeah like this yeah that's tight bunch
of pregnant
slow-mo they gotta walk slow-mo like
yeah they're like oceans a
yeah China's a yeah China's a and act
three is just like 20 women giving birth
yeah aquafina like on a bed legs right
open you know you get it and to give me
shelter though yeah stop watching the
movie they play give yourself to the
whole movie movie though you're like wow
this is really good no who-who did the
soundtrack for it's like 20 tracks how
about that so they're saying that at
least 500 companies have offered such
services in China
five hard well yeah and it's a legal
thing out there to be like yeah come to
America let's come here illegally
tourism right I know of companies like
back in the day where like people are
trying to get citizenship and it's it
was harder and harder to go into the
u.s. so they started having companies go
to Canada and they come back down or
they go to Mexico and they come go back
up so they have so many different
companies to help you get citizenship or
help your kids your citizenship it's a
huge and this is just a different
concept because like we don't ever think
about getting a citizenship elsewhere
and there's rarely like expats of us in
other countries unless it's like they I
don't know unless they just they watch
too much [ __ ] TV they watch all this
[ __ ] news and they're like I'm so
pissed off do you know actually I mean
they always talk about it yeah everybody
talks about don't think anybody does it
I hear everyone's like I'm moving to
Canada moving to Canada they don't
[ __ ] want you I never leave dude
every celebrity who's like if somebody
gets a life and I'm leaving they never
do it you won't I remember it was like
if Bill Clinton gets reelected I'm
leaving I remember the [ __ ] I remember
when I was a kid watching this [ __ ] on
ABC News and [ __ ]
I was Bob Dole and it was like the
degradation of our culture because he
got his dick sucked in office and I was
like get your dick sucked I'm sick I was
11 I'm like it sounds so absolutely sick
good for the guy got his dick stuck just
imagining that is he like weird a shirt
on his like I only get my dicks like the
knob right my mom tried to explain it
she's like don't you Stan Stephen
the Oval Office if that's America is
like office and like the idea of getting
your dicks up there and I'm like yeah
she's trying to convince me why it's bad
call the aural office yeah
I couldn't understand what was bad I was
like just talking to Dixon yeah and I'm
like he's a king right he's like the
American king like can you get his dick
sucked right and I was like maybe it's
my male privilege because I know the
feeling of getting your dick sucked
well I knew what a banana I felt like
sucking my dick so I was like this is
gonna be pretty good want to check those
okay so yeah I was just [ __ ] a banana
but like what do you I was sucking the
mana while I was [ __ ] them okay well
thank you you don't want to go to waste
you know right yeah use a banana peel to
[ __ ] make with any and take the
middle of yeah and I was jamming the
banana into my mouth and that's when
your mom walked in to sing it's enough
to send her into a tailspin all right
yeah speaking of Bill Clinton so my
cousin was saying like in his generation
what he's like 50-something now so like
in the 80s right so like everyone that
knows about the Clintons before that's
why you know that hashtag Clinton body
count thing was going around a lot of
trail of murders happened within that
suspicious suicide deaths yeah and he's
like that yeah so it's like Foster
hashtag Vince Foster but our generation
doesn't really know about that's not
Vince Foster well he was Chelsea
Clinton's father that's another one to
tell me more I've never no joking her
biological father yeah that's what I
heard why I may look similar
why who is it I don't know if it's Vince
Foster
her Webster Webster Hubbell and honestly
I don't care I just don't find it to be
a fun conspiracy it is I forgot what the
details were of it but it's like
Hillary's lover
it's Hillary's real lover Hillary's
actual lover
a man named either Vince Foster or quits
well you gotta go deeper it's because
listen you're watching every bill
they're saying that it's a fake
relationship it's like a YouTube couple
you know it's like obviously yeah I
think that part's been confirmed over
the years yeah just by everyone love in
college use the sense of sight touch
hearing you're smelling your like it's a
[ __ ] chance that part is easy to
understand yeah
but then because of that like they'd be
there they're a power couple right there
there together to like gain power and
work together but they both have their
lovers on the side yes who is Contin
every woman that he walks up to an
include over and underage girls which i
think is very equal yeah he doesn't
discriminate
only against boys that's what I heard
yeah which is [ __ ] up
[Music]